what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel Studios has officially recast
Century for the Thunderbolts and the MCU
now they've made a lot of changes to the
Thunderbolts recently which we'll go
over in this video as they were reported
with this news plus we'll talk about
Kang recasting recasting Kang the
Conqueror the big bad of the MCU I've
seen some people already State they
recast Steven Yun so fast but what about
Jonathan major as K the Conqueror are
they going to recast for the role soon
could they bring Jonathan Majors back
what's the situation there why haven't
we heard anything about it yet we'll go
over all of this in this video and if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all of the latest Marvel MCU news also
doing a big giveaway we'll talk about
that at the end so last week it was
reported that Lewis pman could possibly
be the new century after Steven yon's
Department Steven Yun had to leave due
to scheduling conflicts and just four
days ago on January 25th deadline
reported that Lewis pman was in early
talks to join the Marvel Studios film
The Thunderbolts and today in an article
about a different Thunderbolts change
they slightly confirmed that this has
happened they reported today
Thunderbolts Gerald deine V wathan joins
Marvel Studios pick stepping in for AO
Ed Airi who departs project due to
scheduling that's now the second actor
that they have lost due to scheduling
for the Thunderbolts we'll get back to
this in just a second but in the article
it states viswanathan is the second
recent Edition after the film added
Lewis Pullman to step in for Steven Yun
who departed for similar scheduling
reasons as Ed Airi so it's really
interesting that they didn't do their
own article for the fact that Lewis pman
is now Century in the MCU they simply
added it to this other article about the
Thunderbolts but nevertheless we have
our new century Lewis pman and if you
don't know who he is you might have seen
him in Top Gun Maverick he played Bob
and he was one of the main characters of
the film he did an excellent job playing
the role that he was given and honestly
if he bulks up a little bit and you
picture him with long blonde hair he
kind of does look the part so he's going
to be playing Bob again he's going to be
playing Bob Reynolds Ryan Reynolds in
the movie who of course is century and
he will join the Thunderbolts team now
deadline even States in this article
that they basically don't know who this
new character is going to be that iiri
was before and that now Geraldine
viswanathan is and we haven't really
heard much about the character at all
we're not sure who it is and they even
state that we don't know much about the
project although we do know a little bit
about the project the Thunderbolts based
off of what we have heard from multiple
different insiders over the course of
several months we know that the
Thunderbolts is a team put together by
Valentina algra de Fontaine she's popped
up a lot in the MCU at this point in
time and kind of showed her true colors
and black panther wakanda forever she's
going to go on to be a villain in fact
some insiders say that she is going to
to be the True Villain of the
Thunderbolts team essentially this is
kind of like a suicide squad team
Valentina is going to put together this
team to go on a mission that she doesn't
expect or want any of them to get back
alive from of course there are going to
be subplots throughout the movie and one
of those is we know this they are going
to visit tiamut Island which is what
they are calling the dead Celestial
sticking out of Earth the celestial
tiamut and if you've been following the
news recently you've probably heard that
it said that tiamut is made made out of
Adam mentium which of course is the
metal that's inside of wolverines that
his claws are made of and of course the
US government wants this it's been said
that other governments throughout the
world for other countries want it as
well and there's going to be a decent
fight so this is one of the missions
that the Thunderbolts are going to go on
plus some others as well at least that's
the plan however things kind of changed
thanks to Century if you're somewhat
familiar with Century from the comics
you probably know that he's not exactly
in the best mental state in fact he
suffers from schizophrenia anxiety
disorders and he is a drug addict in
fact that is how he becomes Century he
breaks into a project Century lab which
was doing experiments on the super
soldier serum and takes a project
Century serum which turns him into
Century it gives him the power of 1
million exploding Suns and he took the
serum to get his latest drug fix but
that is not all if you know Century then
you know the void after Robert Reynolds
takes the serum due to his Psych atric
problems he manifests an intensely
malevolent Persona called the void but
his subconscious just as quickly
manifests a balancing heroic Persona the
sentury and both personas are unaware
that they are connected to each other
and the void at one point in time even
attacks New York City and kills a lot of
people and I mean a lot so although we
are unsure of what the exact story for
century is going to be in the
Thunderbolts we know that something goes
wrong because he's a part of the team
and then all of a sudden the
Thunderbolts team has to fight against
him so the void might take over and they
might depict them as just one entity in
the movie maybe something like a dual
personality so Lewis pman is our Century
now it's worth noting that Marvel
Studios is rewriting the Thunderbolts
this is what we knew before they could
change some or maybe even all of this
well not all of it because obviously
century is clearly still going to be in
the film and Marvel Studios clearly has
plans for tyut since he hasn't been a
rest since the eternals this was finally
the opportunity to do so and it makes
sense because this is coming right after
Captain America Brave New World just
five months after we know that
Thunderbolt Ross is still going to be
experimenting with the super soldier
serum perhaps that is how Century comes
into play plus we know he's going to be
the president and most likely is the
person who wants the adamantium from
tyut Island so some aspects of the story
are obviously still the same and Lewis
pman is now our century and again this
has people wondering well what about
recasting King the Conqueror Jonathan
Majors was fired by Marvel Studios
before Steven young exited as centry and
now centry has already been recast
what's the deal with Jonathan Majors
well one of course the most obvious is
that they have more time to cast
Jonathan Majors the Thunderbolts comes
out before the next Avengers film and
based off of what we've heard from
insiders Marvel Studios is still
planning on using K the Conqueror in the
MCU however they kind of want to
sideline him a little bit at least for a
little while supposedly because they
kind of want the hold Jonathan Major's
trial to die down a little bit before
they bring back Kang because they feel
like Kang right now has a negative
connotation if you mention King the
Conqueror people automatically think of
Jonathan majors and some people might
not think very highly right now although
based off of the comments that I've been
seeing in my comment section and online
a lot of people still really want
Jonathan major back a lot of people
believe that he was actually innocent
and that the trial outcome did not
reflect what actually happened and
Jonathan major is going on to appeal
this this has already been confirmed
confirmed by him himself and of course
people are wondering well if he appeals
and then he ends up being found not
guilty will Marvel Studios take him back
and unfortunately that is a question
that we just don't know at this point in
time but that could be a reason another
reason why Marvel Studios is putting off
right now recasting King the Conqueror
they want things to kind of die down a
little bit but they might be waiting to
see what happens when he appeals after
all they did wait until he was found
guilty to fire him that's a lot better
than everybody else did who fired him
right away as soon as they accusations
were made against Jonathan major so
Marvel Studios showed patience before
they could show it again to see what
happens when he appeals but of course we
have no way of knowing that's just
speculation at this point in time but in
the meantime let me know your thoughts
about that in the comments down below
and let me know what you think of Lewis
Pullman being cast as the century and
the Thunderbolts please don't forget to
like this video And subscribe so you can
stay up to date on the MCU and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you are
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the when gets to pick one item and
we pick one winner at the end of each
month you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof